good morning everyone
on behalf of the ukrainian community
here in victoria the ukrainian cultural
center
and the ukrainian canadian congress
victoria branch
i'd like to welcome you to the cultural
center and thank you all so much for
being here
we are truly truly humbled to be the
site of this visit and announcement
and i'd also like to recognize the
traditional territory before we begin
i'm going to acknowledge with respect
that we are on the traditional
territories of the luang and with
saanich first nations
and as a people who are
currently struggling for the territorial
integrity of our own homeland it is so
incredibly important to recognize the
territorial integrity of other
traditional homelands here that we have
the privilege to to live on
um
so i'd like to announce or sorry i'd
like to introduce the
minister
of national defense
to make an announcement
minister
[Applause]
good morning
i am honored to be here at the ukrainian
cultural center in victoria british
columbia
to meet and visit with the local
ukrainian canadian community and to
thank community organizers
who have been helping ukrainians fleeing
violence to resettle here in canada
over the past weeks
organizers right here in victoria have
raised approximately two hundred
thousand dollars to assist ukrainian
newcomers to canada they exemplify the
very best of canada and indeed canadians
when people need our help canadians pull
together
and stand with them
canada and ukraine are more than close
partners
we are family
completed
ukrainians
since the beginning of russia's illegal
invasion of ukraine in 2014
canada has been present to support our
ukrainian friends with comprehensive
military aid
in fact since 2015 the canadian armed
forces have trained over
33 000 members
of ukrainian troops
and it is heartening to see these troops
fighting today with such bravery and
dedication
last month my american counterpart
secretary of defense
austin convened over 40 of ukraine's
defense partners for a conference at
ramstein air base in germany to discuss
what more we could do collectively to
support ukraine's defense needs and
yesterday we met via video link for
another meeting of ukraine's defense
contact group
today i am here to announce the next
package of canadian military aid to
ukraine i can confirm that canada has
purchased over twenty thousand rounds of
one hundred and fifty five millimeter
artillery which is nato's standard
artillery caliber
this package will also include fuses and
charge bags at a cost of up to 98
million dollars
these rounds are compatible with
artillery guns provided by canada and
our allies including the m777 howitzers
that we have donated and which will be
crucial in ukraine's current fight to
defend its eastern territory work is
already underway to deliver this aid to
ukraine as quickly as possible
today's announcement builds on the
military aid that canada has dedicated
to ukraine since 2022 in february
canada's military aid to
ukraine has been comprehensive
we have supplied ukraine
with small arms
specialized equipment like cameras for
military drones
armored vehicles and the heavy artillery
guns i mentioned namely m triple seven
howitzers
and canada has trained ukrainian forces
in the use of these heavy artillery guns
building on the strong relationships our
forces developed with their ukrainian
counterparts through operation unifier
canadian aid continues to flow into
ukraine and we are working around the
clock to identify
and provide even more military aid to
ukraine
with the 500 million dollars that we
announced in budget 2022 for this
purpose
[Applause]
now when we last spoke
my ukrainian counterpart alexey reznikov
told me that canada has been very
helpful
in ukraine's fight against the russian
occupiers and that we are very grateful
that canada stands with us
and we will continue to do just that
conversations
putin's full-scale illegal and
unconscionable invasion of ukraine
cannot be allowed to succeed and it will
not
[Applause]
russian forces have been pushed back
keeve remains free and the maple leaf
flies over the streets of ukraine's
capital once again at our embassy
through military aid economic assistance
humanitarian aid and strong political
support at international forums canada
will continue to have ukraine's back
putin cannot
redraw maps to suit his own needs
sovereign nations cannot be erased from
the map
and the ukrainian people's basic right
to independence and self-determination
cannot be undermined without consequence
thank you merci
[Applause]
hello
um
i will say that canada and ukraine are
very close partners and allies and we
from the very beginning have been
responding to requests that ukraine has
consistently been in touch with us about
the prime minister
and president zielenski speak frequently
and i speak frequently with minister
aleksey reznikov about what continued
military aid we can provide
just a few weeks ago in kiev the prime
minister announced an additional 50
million dollars in military assistance
for ukraine including additional drone
cameras small arms satellite imagery and
m777 ammunition and this adds to the
over 130 million dollars in military aid
that we have already committed today's
announcement builds on those previous
announcements and in particular
canada's purchase of 20 000 rounds of
155 millimeter artillery which is nato's
standard artillery caliber is exactly
what ukraine has asked allies to provide
and is exactly what canada has sourced
and is contributing
that funding hasn't come fairly yet so
they're relying still on charity dollars
here raised as you mentioned in victoria
um
when will that um
yes so let me just take a step back and
speak about military housing as a
general matter
to be clear
across the country canadians are faced
with housing shortages and our
government has the national housing
strategy and committed additional funds
in budget 2022. in terms of military
members and their families
who make incredible sacrifices to serve
canada we will continue to take steps to
ensure that they are supported for
example in february 2021 we increased
military members rates of pay
to ensure alignment with increases
received by the federal public service
we also implemented an interim
relocation policy to enable remote work
options and we also ensure flexibility
for our members and their families when
they're being relocated and to ensure
the post living differential allowance
which is intended to help reduce
financial burdens
we have
the effective support for caf members
and their families and we are seeking to
address through that affordability
concerns we have more work to do in this
area we will continue to support
military members and their families
[Applause]
i would love to chat with families and
members here today if you have a moment
it would be my privilege to speak with
you individually thank you